foreign
so if you want to break a bad habit
there are kind of three potential paths
you could take so the first is you can
eliminate it entirely so elimination
second option is you can reduce it so
you could like curtail it to the desired
degree I don't want to never drink
caffeine I just want to drink less of it
and the third option is you could
substitute it you could replace it with
a different habit and of those three
oftentimes replacing it is actually the
more effective option so for example if
you get your caffeine from drinking Coke
or soda or something like that then
maybe you find out hey you know
something I really love from this
experience is I actually just like
drinking a carbonated beverage and so
it's the carbonation that I like and
maybe if I substitute it with sparkling
water or something like that I still get
the carbonation sensation but I don't
have the caffeine associated with it
anymore and so that's a way of
substituting for that behavior and you
still get something that the experience
provides this is actually kind of an
important just like larger picture big
picture thing about habits which is
every habit that you have we build
habits to solve the repeated problems
that we face in life and I'm using
problems in a very general sense here
you know like let's say that you come
home from work and you feel tired and
exhausted from a long day
well in a sense coming home from work at
6 pm and feeling tired is a problem and
especially if you experience it
repeatedly you got to come up with some
kind of solution for that and generally
speaking we just kind of like try things
out in life and so you can imagine one
person solves the problem of feeling
exhausted by scrolling Instagram
mindlessly for 30 minutes yeah and
another person solves that problem by
playing video games for an hour and a
third person solves it by going for a
run for you know 20 minutes and those
are all solutions to the same kind of
underlying problem but some of them are
more healthy or more productive or
service better than others and what do
you think the odds are that the
solutions you've come up with to the
repeated problems in your life are the
optimal one like it's just so unlikely
that whatever you happen to have
stumbled into throughout life is the
perfect way or the best habit that
serves you most so I think what I'm
trying to get out out there is maybe
take a little bit of the pressure off
yourself and don't worry about judging
yourself so much you're just trying to
solve the repeated problems that you
face but once you realize that it's
unlikely that your current Solutions are
the Optimal Solutions well now maybe we
can step outside and above ourselves and
look down and try to come up with a
better solution so rather than drinking
a Coke to get the carbonation we can
drink Sparkling Water so that's one
example for the substitution
if we want to take the other path of
reduction something I've noticed about
myself is
if I get a six pack of beer and I put it
in the the front of the fridge like in
the door or on a shelf that's like right
at eye level I'll drink one every night
just because it's there but if I take it
and put it on the lowest shelf in the
fridge and like it's kind of all the way
back in the corner I can't really see it
unless I'm bending down
it'll sit there for two weeks or three
weeks like and so I'm like did I want it
or not you know like if it was obvious
then I grabbed one but if it wasn't then
I avoid it and I think that's a simple
question to ask yourself where do I get
my caffeine is it coffee is it soda and
is that really obvious is it like the
coffee's sitting right out on the
counter is the the soda like the first
thing I see at eye level when I open the
fridge and how can I make it less
obvious
in atomic habits they're kind of what I
call the four laws of behavior change
and it's just this big picture view of
how to build a good habit and so if you
want to build a good habit you want to
make your habits obvious attractive easy
and satisfying and if you want to break
a bad habit you just do the opposite of
those four so you want to make it
invisible make it unattractive make it
difficult make it unsatisfying and so I
think how can you make coffee or soda
invisible how can you make it difficult
to drink like keep it outside of the
house Etc so there are a variety of
strategies you could use here you know
like let's say you live with a family
and other people are going to want to
drink it but you don't want to well
there's a there's this little kind of
diabolical tupperware container called
the kitchen safe and it has a lock box
code on the top of it and so you could
give the other family members the lock
box code but then they don't give it to
you and you just put the soda inside of
that and so it stays in that Tupperware
and you can't access it so finding ways
to increase friction or to make it
difficult or to make it less obvious
those are all ways to potentially
curtail
the the caffeine habit